here in Berlin Chancellor Angela
Merkel's cabinet is due to approve
legislation that should help skilled
workers from outside the European Union
find jobs in Germany the country
urgently needs people to fill more than
a million job vacancies
now the proposed law would simplify the
process for recognizing professional or
a vocational training degrees from
abroad it would also eliminate the
requirements that employers have to
check whether a German nationals are
also able to fill available whether to
fill the vacancy and it would allow
qualified non-eu Nationals who do speak
German to live in the country while they
look for work but what about asylum
seekers should qualified migrants who've
been denied refugee status be allowed to
stay if a company wants them
DW Eleazar Bock met an Iraqi who has
skills and wants to use them here in
Germany Kira's acaba G is nervous he has
to give a presentation to the whole team
today the 40 year old Iraqi is an
apprentice at an IT company in Cologne
like most of his colleagues here at FRG
has only lived in Germany for a few
years they here from Syria Iran and Iraq
and they all came to Germany as refugees
mr. chance this is a great chance for me
it's difficult to get a job training
position here husband looked so offended
three years ago al-kahf AG's request for
asylum was denied his official status
since then has been what Germany terms
tolerated right to state this
apprenticeship will give him a chance of
staying longer the skills he's learning
are in demand here there are 80 to 100
thousand positions in the IT branch
alone that cannot be filled due to lack
of qualified workers
up until now the problem was if you get
someone who's not European then there is
a risk that they are not going to be
able to stay at the end of the day you
need a visa and what am I going to do if
they don't get a visa or if I have a job
to fill but a German or European has to
do it then the whole process was a waste
of time Germany needs immigrants
otherwise its economic growth will slow
down considerably experts estimate that
in around ten years there will be a
shortage of 3 million trained skilled
workers the new migration law now is
designed to address this problem to make
it easier for skilled labour from
outside of the you to move here but
still some questions remain how will the
new migration laws affect people working
in Germany whose asylum requests were
denied they may be granted a tolerated
right to stay status for another two
years yet there is still a stark
demarcation between those seeking asylum
and the migration of trained
professionals to Germany we're a small
company and if after three years we were
told that colleague has to return to his
or her country of origin that would be a
setback not just financially or from a
business perspective but also personally
Osama beat are from Syria is the newest
instructor he has been under contract as
an IT specialist since April o kafaja is
his first apprentice he still has one
year to go and hopes all will go well
and to complete my training and get a
job and stay here in Germany that would
make me really happy and satisfied this
civilian hon Douglas
polakov watches boss is hoping things
will get simpler with the new law so he
can keep his specialists and employ new
ones as well our political correspondent
Hans Brandt is with us for more on this
story hi Hans good morning to you let's
talk about fear us who we saw there in
that report Oh will this legislation
that the cabinet is set to approve today
here in Germany make it easier for
people like him to stay in this country
that's been one of the big controversies
the question has been whether or not
this law should allow people who have
come into the country for other reasons
as asylum seekers as refugees or
illegally but have found a job
eventually whether there should be
allowed to stay or not I think what will
happen we don't know the exact terms of
this law yet but so far the proposals
that we have seen there will be some
clause allowing these people to stay and
in fact at the moment they are already
being tolerated their status is a one of
being tolerated
more or less indefinitely so in in
effect these people will be allowed to
stay I thank you and we have heard from
German companies time and again that
there is a need for skilled workers
which industries are experiencing a
shortage I think the what we what we
talk about most most often is is
engineering jobs and computer jobs IT
jobs these are the companies that are
most desperately looking for people for
for for workers but also within things
like hospital work or old-age care
there's a big need in Germany so it's
really right across the spectrum of
German employment and this legislation
would allow skilled workers in the
country also from non EU countries we
should say why is the issue of migration
so controversial politically here in
Germany well there's been a discussion
especially in the site on the side of
conservative parties of the Christian
Democrats angular Merkel's party and to
say that Germany should not become an
immigration country one of these classic
immigration countries that would
normally be you would think about
countries such as Canada or Australia or
the United States who have been pulling
in people from across the world really
since the the countries were founded
and Germany has not been like that and
the Conservatives have been saying that
we that they would like to preserve kind
of German identity within Germany but
they're really fighting a rearguard
action here the situation is such that
Germany really does need such skilled
workers and that in fact a very large
number of people maybe 30 or 40 percent
of people living in Germany today
already have some kind of foreign
background so in the end the reality is
such that Germany will need these
skilled workers and making it easier for
them to come in will be very beneficial
for the country all right
our political correspondents Brent with
us here this morning thank you so much